Aspetta, ce la faccio, ce la faccio..
Benvenuti su Anita Stories oggi nuovissimo video
super speciale, avete capito dove ci
troviamo?
siamo al parco giochi DaDa party. Vi
ricordate, tempo fa abbiamo già fatto un
video qua e vi è piaciuto tantissimo!
Ci hanno ospitato nuovamente qua al DaDa
party e oggi faremo un video speciale e cioè
giocheremo a ROBLOX nella vita reale
se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace
"Vitale non si sfracella più!" - faremo un altro video qui al DaDa party, quindi lasciate un
bel mi piace qua sotto; Se vi ricordate
questa ludoteca DaDa party è enorme, infatti
ci sono due sale quindi sarà super
divertente questo Roblox nella vita reale
Ringraziamo DaDa party per averci
ospitato e... iniziamo
subito la challenge
Primo quadro della nostra challenge di
Roblox, dobbiamo superare questi ostacoli
questo primo quadro del parkour per
ora è molto semplice, bisogna evitare gli
ostacoli ma c'è Vitale che è già morto ecco Vitale che
ricomincia, devi evitarli gli ostacoli non
devi andarci contro
Salta!
Avanti!
Si! ce l'hai fatta!
Oh no! Questa è super difficile, bisogna andare piano
piano
Speriamo che cada....
[Musica]
eccomi! Tocca a me superare questo
quadro devo sbrigarmi perché Vitale è
già più avanti e ovviamente vincerà chi
finisce prima il parkour e prende il badge
finale per primo! Quindi Sbrighiamoci!
Hey, un piccolo ostacolo
io in realtà ho un trucchetto perché ho le
calze con questi gommini sotto quindi
scivolo meno forse.. hey, ma è facilissimo qua
mi basta camminare
ed evitare tutti gli ostacoli, saltiamo il
primo ostacolo e poi qua!
Hey! Aspetta un momento, tu non sei passato qua
vero? ..emh.. ho preso una scorciatoia.. sono passato di qua...
Tu sei passato solo di qua!!
ce l'ho fatta!! .... Devo completare questo
quadro che inizia di qua e finisce
la giù
Ma adesso devo sbrigarmi, Anita sta
arrivando.. corro
sembra un cono di gelato.. Argh!
Ma quindi, non è un cono di gelato.. eccomi
Vitale ti sto raggiungendo... Argh!
ma che sta facendo Vitale... V: ma forse il
cono è solo questo giallo...  proviamo a
prenderlo..
A: sempre il solito che si deve sfracellare
10.000 volte beh, meglio così
approfittiamone e superiamolo
permesso permesso permesso
ma come faccio a salire la sopra?
sicuramente devo evitare quello... perché
Vitale non è tornato in vita ancora? Hey?!
V: Non toccare questo non sono gelati!!
A: ma va? Si vede benissimo che non sono gelati
quante volte ti sei sfracellato già? Emhh... 3 - 4???
2?  A: secondo voi chi vincerà questa
challenge io o Vitale??  Ma soprattutto
quante volte si sfracellerà Vitale?
"Scrivetelo nei commenti!!" E ora meglio che supero Vitale
Aspetta Aspetta!
Bisogna salire la sopra!!!
Come si fa a salire la sopra?
V: di qua! Vado!
A: ma dove stai andando? ma che stai facendo? ATTENTO!
V: ho sbagliato strada non è questa...
A: è vero non è questa, penso.. perché qua c'è
uno scivolo quindi... bisogna salire su..
Anche se li c'è una scorciatoia... è un po un
labirinto questo.. Hey ma qua è tutto
chiuso, dove dobbiamo andare? Devo
sbrigarmi vado di la...aahh
V: non mi scappi
A: attento! non toccare le pareti altrimenti muori!
V: quali pareti? A: attento non toccare qua! V: ok
A: devo cercare di spostarmi qua senza
toccare niente..
ce l'ho fatta!
vediamo se Vitale ce la farà...
V: Si, ho capito
A: che cos'è quella? V: non l'avevo visto...!
A: tanto tu non ci passi da lì.. V: come non ci
passo? stavo facendo il delfino
spiaggiato qui! Evviva!!! io prendo la scorciatoia!
A: ti avevo detto di non toccare li...
Come sempre Vitale non mi ascol..
è meglio che non tocco questi ostacoli
comunque come sempre Vitale non mi
ascolta.. li c'è una scorciatoia ma è
impossibile passare perché è troppo
stretto e non bisogna toccare le altre
parti.. quindi
"forse è meglio continuare di qua! ma non lo dico a Vitale"  lui continuerà
a provare a salire la sopra.. ihihih
V: che cosa on devi dire a Vitale? A: niente niente
vai pure
vai, sali pure la sopra....
nel mentre che Vitale continua a
sfracellarsi io passo qua d'avanti
cercando di superare questi ostacoli
sperando che sia la strada giusta e non
che la strada giusta sia quella di sopra
ma lo scopriremo molto presto... V: CHE COSA??? Questa è
la strada giusta?
Si, certo che è.... Noo, è quella in cui
stai andando tu... io vado... ciao... V: Mi stai imbrogliando!
A: ma che sta facendo? sta strisciando verso di qua? V: eh si! per non toccare la parte di sopra
ahh, ha deciso di seguirmi...
vai piano... mah? che stai facendo?
V: è aumentata la difficoltà
V: ce la faccio, ce la faccio... boing!
Povero Vitale mi fa un pò pena.. quante
volte si sta sfracellando, beh almeno
sono in vantaggio.. V: questa volta ce la faccio!
meno male hai tante vite come i gatti
anche se dovrei essere io un gatto in
questo caso.. comunque super divertente
questa challenge di Roblox nella
vita reale vero?
V: SUPERdivertente, mi sono sfracellato 1000 volte già!
A: proprio come nel videogioco
Guardate cosa c'è qua! V: vado avanti io... A: oh no!
Vitale mi ha superato
devo inventarmi subito
qualcosa... hey Vitale ho trovato una cosa
bellissima
hai presente i coni gelato che cercavi
prima.. V: SI! A: Guarda, c'è un cono gelato gigante qua
uno al cioccolato e uno alla vaniglia
V: NO! Non ci casco! Passo di qua!
A: non ci credo che è riuscito a passare
la in mezzo! come hai fatto? V: mi sono messo
di traverso... A: ora ci provo io...
sto arrivando
[Musica]
V: hai toccato! ahahahah
ok, provo di lato
Ci sei riuscita! ma dove dobbiamo andare adesso?! V: Non lo so...
Io sto provando da questa parte un po a caso
A: ma come a caso? io stavo seguendo te
perchè pensavo sapessi la strada!
V: non mi devi mai seguire!! Lo sai che io non conosco la strada!
Ma che sta facendo
Vitale crede davvero di riuscire a
passare la in mezzo??!!
[Musica]
V: ce l'ho fatta!!!!!!
A: NOOO sei morto perché hai toccato gli ostacoli!
Ma che stai facendo? fermo!
ma che stai facendo?
Vitale non riesce più ad alzarsi in piedi!
V: Ma dove siamo?
Ma non è questa la parte giusta!!! NO!!
A: Ti sei accorto adesso che sei tornato dove eri prima?
Bene questa è l'occasione giusta
perché mentre Vitale è incastrato là
dentro
io posso tornare di là alle entrate e
provare a salire da sopra, nella parte
che abbiamo visto prima... ciao ciao Vitale
Forse vincerò io!!  V: NO! Vincerò io! Ci provo da qui!
Oh no! Che sta facendo!?
Ti si vedono le mutande!!
V: Ops...
è un po difficile perchè scivolo!!
A: guarda che non riesci a salire
da la sopra! V: infatti si scivola!
A: ti conviene tornare indietro...
dai secondo me puoi farcela provaci
ancora
ecco vitale che prova a salire sullo scivolo
ma ha le calze troppo scivolose!
dai riprova puoi farcela!
riprovaci varie volte così rimarrai lì
per un bel po di tempo io nel frattempo
provo a salire da qua!
La c'è un altro passaggio....
Vitale sta continuando a provare a salire
dallo scivolo ma non penso che ci
riuscirà mai....
Non penso di riuscirci a salire qua sopra ma
ci provo... che sta facendo Vitale??
Sta provando a salire da li??
guarda che non si può salire da li!
... è scomparso..
..devo cercare di non toccare niente
forse ci sono riuscita... ora la parte più difficile
solo le gambe
posso toccare la parte gialla ma non
posso toccare la parte verde di sotto
il problema è che non posso toccare neanche
questa parte verd..
ho avuto un'idea migliore vi ricordate
che vi ho detto che io le calze con i
gommini sotto antiscivolo... potrei
riuscire a salire dallo scivolo, invece che
passare da qua che è difficilissimo... andiamo
ok eccomi tornata qua devo solo superare
questi ostacoli adesso.... ma dov'è finito
Vitale non c'è più...
Non mi dire che è uscito dal gioco...
forse si era stancato perché si è
sfracellato così tante volte che ha
deciso di uscire dal gioco che strano..
vabbè.. noi continuiamo
ma come ha fatto prima Vitale a passare
qua... forse devo per forza buttarmi ok
eccomi devo buttarmi
quasi quasi faccio un riposino qua... ah no
devo trovare Vitale e anche finire l'escape room
e prendere il badge prima di
Vitale.... proviamo a salire dallo scivolo
con le mie calze anti-scivolo! calze
antiscivolo con i gommini e anche le
orecchie da gatto proprio come un vero
gatto!!!!
andiamo!! ecco qua lo scivolo
o no la mia calza scivola lo stesso..
le calze antiscivolo
dovrebbero non farmi scivolare ma
scivolano lo stesso..... in questo caso
sarebbe stato utile Vitale per aiutarmi...
mi avrebbe potuto dare una mano e
trascinarmi sopra.... riproviamo
devo provare a salire velocissimamente!
posso farcela
inutile non ce la faccio... dove sarà finito Vitale!
perché ha lasciato il gioco
proprio adesso.. ho bisogno del suo aiuto
non ce la farò mai
V: ma tu sei qua... aspetta ti do una
mano! A: Eri qua tutto il tempo?
Certo! dai, ti aiuto io! A: ok grazie!
A: Si ci sono quasi...
V: aspetta un momento... ma tu prima mi hai
fatto sfracellare migliaia di volte.. A: No no no no
[Musica]
A: te ne pentirai, mi vendicherò!
V: ti ho fregata.. io continuo l'escape room.. ciao
A: mi hai imbrogliata!
Vediamo se riesce ad evitare tutti gli ostacoli
un altro ostacolo
ma come sta camminando?
dentro al tubo?
Vitale sta continuando ad andare avanti ed io
non riesco a salire in questo scivolo!
Sembra così piccolo e facile da salire,
ma è difficilissimo
beh mi resta solo una cosa da fare, tornare
indietro e riprovare a salire da la!
ok posso toccare il giallo ma non il
verde
devo stare attenta qua sopra!
Mi devo spostare qua
qua non devo toccare
ma come faccio a salire qua sopra
se è verde?
devo per forza appoggiarmi qua
per fortuna in questa posso appoggiarmi
ce l'ho fatta!! Qua è dov'era Vitale prima
lo riconoscete? Vedete, quello è lo scivolo
e Vitale prima è passato da la
eccolo! sta arrivando! Che cosa vuole fare?
Aiuto, sta arrivando qua
A: Ahahahah, ennesimo sfracellamento di Vitale..
io devo sbrigarmi, magari passo di la...andiamo.. spero che non venga qua!   V: Dove stai andando senza di me!
A: Mi hai imbrogliata prima nello scivolo!
V: Anche tu mi hai imbrogliato prima
Scappiamo da Vitale, altrimenti mi
butterà negli ostacoli
Sta arrivando!!
Fermo li!
Hey ma che fai? V: Ti tiro gli ostacoli!
Prendi questi ostacoli! ma dove stai scappando?
Aspetta un momento...
non c'è una via d'uscita qua...
V: effettivamente era un po che giravo in
torno qui... A: Se passo di qua, torno dove ero
prima.. ma qual è la via d'uscita allora?
V: Non lo so ma...
credo sia quella l'uscita c'è anche il
badge... A: è vero! dobbiamo trovare il modo di
andare laggiù, ma allora dobbiamo
tornare al piano di sotto!
V: credo proprio di sì e io credo di essere
avvantaggiato perché da qui è più facile.. ciaooo
Mi stai intralciando la strada
A: sei tu che mi stai intralciando, vai dall'altra!
V: NO! mi metto qui, dovrei passare su di me!
A: Sembri un bruco dentro una mela verde..
V: vorrà dire che mi trasformerò in una
bellissima farfalla addio... A: fermo! passo da
questa parte allora in questo tubo
giallo
lui è già laggiù
Ha già superato tutti gli ostacoli!
Ah ah! Ben ti sta! così impari a correre... io meglio
che vado piano così evito di
sfracellarmi un sacco di volte.... questo è un
aiutante? sembra proprio un personaggio di
ROBLOX
V: AH!!! credevi mi fossi arreso! e invece no...
Vado avanti!
qua serviranno le mie calze antiscivolo
devo andare a prendere, raggiungere Vitale
non devo toccare le reti e non devo
cadere
per fortuna ho queste calze
ce l'ha fatta! Dove è andato?
nello scivolo!!!! V: ciao ciao perdente!!
A: sto arrivando, hey fermo lì, ora
ti raggiunto subito
V: Aiuto, aiuto!!!
A: dov'è andato? Sto arrivando!
V: io sono in vantaggio
V: fammi andar via!
ahia ahia
Si è spiaccicato in questo ostacolo...
aspetta c'è l'uscita qui!
l'uscita era qua
e non ce ne siamo accorti..? noi siamo saliti
fin la sopra, ma l'uscita era
qua a fianco.. come mai non ti sei accorto?
vabbè, Vitale sta cercando di evitare
l'ostacolo
ahhhnnnn era qui l'uscita!! Viaaaa
Vitale mi sta superando devo correre sta
arrivando al badge
Fermo!!!
Non riesce a camminare!
V: Sto prendedno il badge
Vitale è caduto due volte
ora che lui è a terra, posso
approfittarne per prendere il badge prima di
lui! Andiamo! Spero di non cadere anchio.. V: te lo impedirò! Non lo prenderai!
Ci sono quasi!
no
Si, l'ho preso! Evviva!
Ho vinto!
siccome ho vinto ti aiuto ad alzarti
V: Ci vuole una gru! prendo anche io il badge
anche sei l'hai preso prima tu!
Escape room superata!
ma??
Se volete vedere un'altra escape room
anche nell'altra area di DaDa party
lasciate un bel mi piace, a 20 mila mi
piace faremo la seconda parte!! A 20 mila mi
piace faremo la seconda parte di Roblox nella
vita reale, ringraziamo ancora DaDa Party
per averci ospitato, potete trovare
DaDa parti in via di circonvallazione
di lizzanello 56 a Lecce, Cavallino
Ora vi lasciamo qua, 4 caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video, cliccate su quella che
preferite e.... buona visione, CIAO!!!